[Music]
lieutenant sir why are we here it's
zombies again fast ones are slowing sir
slow thank god they're slow
next stop Pleasant Valley
[Music]
Oh Teddy we're having a super fun time
on our trip
[Music]
must be something in the way
Oh be scared numbers have to play tag
well those funny-looking people out
there we're all gonna die I live on the
diamond Carol I know this part of the
game the zombies are not real
there's a bit scary we can't stay here
indefinitely
I'm not going anywhere you're bigger
idiots than I thought and I thought you
were both the stupidest people I've ever
met my job is to keep you safe stay here
until I get back that kind of behavior
is unacceptable let's start now that is
five years old and if you can't use
appropriate language with a
five-year-old I'm going to have to ask
you to doesn't have attracted and wait
for Haas
[Music]
how do you like it oh god what have I
done
what's that oh I got caught in the
middle of a jam fight
don't take it okay
[Music]